okay my next guest oh you all know my
next guest CNBC Jay Leno's Garage new
episodes air may 20th at 10 o'clock on
the East Coast he is the only man to be
twice fired for being the crime for
committing the crime of being number one
in the ratings Jay Leno hello Jay great
to see you over there wherever you are
and gosh I wish we were meeting under
better circumstances I know you've
always been kind of a glasses half full
guy right have you been able to maintain
that kind of optimism even in these
times I am optimistic you know I saw
this doctor foul Qi that's and that's I
say it from yes of course and I watched
my TV and he says this virus is a war we
had to fight it like a war and the
reporter says to him well how do we do
that he says by staying home and
watching TV and I said it myself if
there was ever a war Americans are
qualified qualified to fight it I mean
I've been training this my whole life if
they had hold and watch TV really how
hard is it like I saw I'm not a
celebrity was but I saw him on one of
the shows and he said I feel like a
prisoner of war in my own home and I
went the difference between this war is
when the prisoners released they're
fatter when the war is over the
prisoners are fatter than when the war
began yes is the only crisis where you
could see a celebrity telling you not to
panic from their panic room exactly
exactly and and and the support team we
have mama Celeste chef boyardee Jerry
and Jemima they're all helping us build
a helping us get through it thank God so
Jay look I don't want to give away where
you live exactly because there's crazy
people out there but I think people know
you're a very successful guy so let's
just say somewhere in the Southern
California area where the very rich
people live I live in a similar kind of
neighborhood it's a little a little
different how the rich areas are
handling this don't you think yes it is
I mean it is just
and well I mean Beverly Hills is
affecting celebrities to react
differently like I read you know Jesse
Smollett yes of course okay it's a
little paranoid
he actually had two guys beat him up on
FaceTime yeah to get our daughter into
Medical School because they wanted it
home Wow yeah so yeah are you uh are you
still driving because I I've taken the
car out a number of times just so it
doesn't freeze up in the garage for
nowhere to friggin go right and it's one
of the few things you can do or you're
not hurting anybody you're alone in the
car but it's it's it's depressing having
you join I'm driving traffic I mean oh
yes you realize this in the last three
weeks they've given out two thousand
tickets for people going well over a
hundred miles an hour on the 101 in the
405 no truth yeah that's true because
people they've never seen it like this
right so um what about food Jay you know
you and I have never really seen
eye-to-eye on food food I was just
talking to dr. Katz a very important
part of immunity I've never known you to
eat a vegetable in your life you you
know and it's affecting the way people
live you know because it's the economy I
mean I saw a Mafia don picking up food
to go at an Olive Garden oh my god
that's bad well the economy is you know
I worry so much about the economy I saw
Louis Farrakhan wearing a clip-on bow
tie that's how bad that is a bad economy
I think do you have any other examples
of why the economy something what in
West Hollywood
I saw a gay bar having ladies night
that's how bad you actually good to have
ladies night at a gay bar it's maybe a
dated joke there when okay so I saw Tom
Selleck get turned down for reverse
mortgage that's how bad it that is
that's terrible that's terrible so Jay
you're home now
you're a road warrior yeah I'm not
nearly the road war
you are but I am on the road all the
time as people watch the show No
it always ends except in these days with
me saying I'll be at right and now
there's no I'll be at but for a guy like
you who has you know how many nights a
week do you did you work before that I
was doing 210 dates a year 210 yeah okay
nights a week so that's like five nights
a week how are you coping what's your
wife doing with you home she must be
going nuts no no it's okay I like to
spend time with my wife and you know
that she no it's good see the nice thing
about being married 40 years see this is
different this is something you could
never do with a 25 year old but when
you're married 40 years like my wife and
I sat down to watch a Netflix movie I
fell asleep about halfway through I woke
up I said what happened she said I don't
know I fell asleep so he said good we
can watch again tomorrow
actually watch this Netflix movie three
times because I never quite made it to
the end so it's okay you know something
I can live in whatever environment I'm
forced into and I was always one of
those guys I never want to be one of
those performers who turned down a job
coz when I when I started out you know
how does we start this quarter don't
work so I never won how much money I'm
not going for that money what do you
rent for that much money in a Tuesday
night you can't go through that job but
now I'm forcing it so I'm now I'm forced
to actually relax and take time off and
I'm enjoying it and you know something
if there is a good side to this I talked
to a friend of mine who was in Italy he
said for the first time there was fish
in the canals in Venice Rome you know
and the ocean seems a little cleaner la
seems remarkably cleaner because planes
are not flying this is sort of like
Nature's Way of dealing with global
warming yeah I mean the oil oil is zero
dollars per barrel
you cannot literally give it away right
at this point who would have thought
last year at $100 about this could
happen so it's almost like the earth is
sort of healing itself I know I sound
like some sort of new agey person
obviously I'm not but so I'm just trying
to see the good side obviously it's a
horrible thing in people are suffering
and that's terrible but that's just one
of the after ok well I know you were
always a guy who helps when crisis comes
along and you're the thing you're doing
I think is so marvelous you have a 3d
printer in your garage yeah we have a
couple of you know making masks right
we're making the master would make him
free and I was gonna bring I don't know
I left it at home it's it's a mask with
the glass you know the plastic clear
plastic front and we make them when we
give them to the fire department they
hand them out to first responders and
hospital workers and the 3d printers one
24 hours a day and they just keep
Chinese out turn these out at the end of
the week we give them all to the fire
department and they hand them out and
it's fun I mean it's great to feel like
you're part of something you're actually
sort of helping out not just you know
having food delivered w5 minutes you
know right so so that's that's good I
mean don't you have a mask with you
another kind of mask that you do an
impression with J do you have that no I
had a joke I had a coronavirus joke for
you go ahead let me see okay old guy in
the hospital's got a touch on nurse
comes in you all right guy goes yeah
nurse could you check to see if my
testicles are black yes cuz sir I can't
do that I'm just an engine no we just
checked to see if my testicles are black
says there's okay yeah thanks a truck
going by those backyard when you love on
Van Nuys Boulevard ins what you get
anyway so guys sitting there he goes up
cactus in my testicle is a bless you no
sir I'm not even a registered nurse I'm
just a trick just that's why I'm asking
just check to see if my testicles are
black all right
said she reaches up under the guise down
there and looks she goes sir you find
the guy goes now I said check to see if
my test results are back
you